congratulations on the show
um I was so hooked from the start with
this it is so twisty and like mysterious
I just loved it so much and you know
when this came your way how much did you
know about the production in the book I
didn't actually didn't know the book so
it was really exciting to be introduced
to the material
um and and find out that it was this
massive bestseller
um and also that the show was gonna be
uh like both uh an expression of the
book but then something bigger and and
broader you know and to have Laura Dave
you know like as the writer and Josh
singer um so the you know the woman that
created the book then me writing the
show
um you know to me it was an opportunity
for her and for all of us to explore
this world that she had built and
honestly to flesh it out even more
because Jules is actually a much more
robust character on the series than she
was in the book and so that was really
exciting for me yeah I loved that part
so I've read the book and I loved seeing
that there was more of like a
personality and liveliness to jewels and
to see her take so much like you know
charge and decisions and choices and
being there for Hannah I love that so
much and you know so your character
she's incredible and I love how she's
fleshed out in this and she's a
hard-working reporter who really lives
by the truth was that something that
really attracted you to the role when
they put it on paper and they showed you
like here's who Jules is going to be
yeah I mean she was just smart and tough
and the kind of friend that you know any
of us would want in a crisis because she
wasn't just the kind of friend that was
there to make Hannah feel better she was
the person who was going to tell Hannah
the truth and I think as this story
unfolds and you know Hannah's telling
herself well you know I know I know
everything's you know it's gonna be okay
she's kind of telling herself a certain
story about what's going on with Owen
Jules is like listen I got to tell you
something like it this doesn't look good
and I love you enough to tell you the
truth and I really I loved that about
the characters she was she was tough she
was No Nonsense she was smart she was
the kind of person that was going to
help Hannah unravel this mystery but
also the kind of friend that any of us
would want in our lives because you know
I always say this like I like a good
time but I am not a good time friend I'm
gonna be a real friend to you in a case
that means that you know I got to give
you the truth and I respect and love you
enough to tell you you know what's
really going on yeah and there were some
very questionable scenes with Jules that
legit had me scared he's scared for her
well-being like like I wasn't sure what
was going to happen and I didn't know
because there were certain changes in
the book so I thought maybe they would
kind of change things in this direction
too but she's fearless in the face of
all of it and I just love that so much
did you learn anything about yourself
when playing a character like this oh
wow that's a good question
um yeah I mean Jules is really fearless
and I liked that about her uh
I don't know there was nothing that
happened on the series that I thought I
wouldn't do in real life but I don't
know maybe if I was being pursued by
Mysteries and dark Forces I I would I
would take a vacation I have no idea I
like to think that I would be the kind
of friend
um who would fight as hard as Jules
fights for Hannah
um and also you know because she is a
journalist and she's gone through so
much in her own personal life I think
that gave her a toughness and a
self-awareness that really propelled her
forward and helped Propel Hannaford
which I I really loved about her but
um we all think we're gonna be a
superhero in the face of danger but I I
honestly I have no idea maybe I'd hide
under the bed yeah I thought it was so
nice also that we saw Max sort of like
different from the book and the book
she's you know a male it's like in here
we get to see it's a same-sex couple and
you guys are very close and you work
together collaborate on like helping
Hannah and I'm wondering how was that
sort of dynamic working with her on set
and like you know having that character
and like building a relationship like a
backstory to that I just loved how that
relationship unfolded because you know
Max and Jules
approached this whole thing very
differently and I even think that for
Max she's a bit more skeptical about
what's going on you know Jules has this
tie to Hannah and so she's really driven
to help Hannah doesn't mean she's going
to compromise her values but she's
leaning in a little harder than Max
wants to at the beginning and then Max
and Hannah really do come together in a
way that I think is uh competent and
smart and and built on trust and and
built on a desire for the truth
um but you know Max also wants to
protect Jules she's like listen I don't
want you to getting tangled up and this
this guy looks like he's a crook you
know what I mean and you're a journalist
you need to protect yourself and you
need to protect us
um but I I do like that both Jules and
Max really step outside of themselves to
help someone who's going through a
crisis
um and make the kinds of personal
sacrifices that I hope that I would make
on behalf of a friend if they needed me
and um I love the uh friendship between
you and Jennifer's role you guys are
like lifelong friends it plays well into
the series you have a great chemistry
how did you prepare for that like did
you know her prior to filming how did
that work out
um one of the weird things about being
in this industry is you feel like you
know everybody personally even when you
don't which I guess maybe have some
people who like love somebody from afar
too like oh I feel like I know Jennifer
but
um we essentially like met on the show
and had to be best friends right away
but she's such a warm lovely person to
be around that it was a very easy role
to fall into she's a blast she's just so
good at her job so confident so
confident
um and really makes me feel at home when
you step on set so it was a very it was
very easy to pretend to be your best
friend I honestly thought you guys had
worked together because there was such
an ease there and I was like looking
through your imdbs and I'm like no they
haven't I'm like that's crazy but it's
you know you guys are work really well
together it's great and even with angry
too like I felt like there was such a
nice relationship there like she was
sort of like a surrogate Aunt to her yes
taking care of her also what was I like
working with her she's such a wonderful
young actress angry is such a great
actress and uh I was and I also felt
like she was somebody that I knew right
away as well
um and I just that it was so funny
because I was like where do I go from it
was she played uh the daughter on the
nice in the movie The Nice Guys I was
like
walk back to us and we had just like
this we I mean we had several scenes
together but we had this one really
beautiful moment where we got to kind of
talk about what she was going through
she's a delight to work with
um a really really accomplished young
actress and uh and you know like a part
of your job as an actor is to support
the other actor in your scene right to
really like lift them up and give them
the energy that's going to help them do
their best work and hopefully vice versa
and she's just incredibly generous and
present and just so peachy like she was
a blast yeah I love that and you know
knowing that Laura Dave helped develop
this for TV and it's so clear to the
series too I'm I'm wondering like you
know obviously there have been TV shows
based on books that have expanded past
the story so if we ever got a season two
would you be up for it and like where
would you want to see your character oh
wow I mean I would love to to revisit
these characters again it was so much
fun and it would be so interesting and
intriguing to see what would happen in a
second season it's so great that Laura
Dave is a part of the show I mean you
know an integral part of the show
because it's her world she built it so
you know I would be super excited to see
you know what's what's cooking in her
mind what's percolating in there in
terms of where we would go with the
second season and I anything more that I
say will give too much away about the
first season but yeah but yeah I mean I
I love this world it's it's so rich and
Intrigue driven and there's so much more
that could be done here so um and with
Laura and Josh they're just they have
incredible creative minds and uh it
would be a blast it would be a blast to
to revisit this world yeah I would love
that so much and I
is you know this is such a beautiful
story of love and loyalty and it stuck
with me for days I was still thinking
about it and I've binged the show twice
already I'm wondering like what is the
biggest takeaway you want audiences to
carry with them from this series you
know what's interesting about this show
is that it it's constantly uh changing
and evolving this is really you know
obviously very twisty it's very entry
driven it's a psychological Thriller but
it's really about
um loving someone uh in not you know
maybe maybe not in spite of who they
were before but because of it but we
could never really know everybody fully
and you really it's a leap of faith it's
really an Act of Faith to love someone
and you just decide I'm gonna jump in
with both feet
um you know I think some people don't
want to fall in love because they're
afraid they're gonna get hurt but you
know that's no way to move through the
world you know and whether it's a day or
a week or a month or a year like you
know but the old quote is you know it's
better to have loved and lost than never
to have loved at all and I think
um you know there's a line that Hannah
says almost immediately in the show
which is like I don't know what this
guy's done but I know who he is and I
think we all would like that that that
kind of love from someone
um that will help us transcend you know
who we were in the past and make us a
better version of ourselves yeah yeah
definitely well Aisha thank you so much
for your time it has been such a
pleasure chatting with you and
congratulations on the show again it's
really so good I'm just so addicted to
it I love it so much